pas à moi à l'école ça fait un moment
que c'est terminé sa partie une
espérance non non ça ne fait pas ça ne
fait pas ça l'est via rien je vais
prendre une feuille c'est un stylo bleu
quand justin theroux je prenne pas tant
parce que bon c'est pas le mieux c'est
que l'on a peur
est-ce que je saisisse pas les avoir
tous acteurs [ __ ] les pieds même pas
la triche et l'élève qui travaillent
pour les services secrets
l'élève voleurs de blaye ou intégrale
elle est douce parce que l'épilation
intégrale et on a intégré les doutes
parce que l'épilation intégrale et demi
tube et passion cyprien zéro parce que
tu rigole pas eugénie l'élection donné
mardi le coup que tu coupes aux
extrémités la pression effectuée que
mesurée en pascal thomasse caladons
projectiles
humidifiez au bout on va voir son balcon
l'exercice 2 sera pas la réponse ne
s'est pas dire donc effectivement époque
tu as fait la pression élèves tout le
temps dit charles aujourd'hui un
physique plus petit jamais au courant
contre rouge et pas au courant j'ai pas
révisé anglais [ __ ] en histoire en
cours vous êtes au professeur ludwig et
dont vous êtes le coiffer tout le monde
sur une feuille s'il vous plaît exercice
au tableau l'élève qui est trop beau
doublé c'est à dire sur ces conseils de
classe le pro victimes nous allons
commencer notre introduction sur les
sciences
julien arrête ça tout de suite monsieur
vient il pas lol ah oui vous tous pour
moi désolé donc les cieux le prof qui si
tout l'économiste adam smith n'est ce
pas avec sa théorie de jimmy arrête de
tirer la morge d'adèle à 4 août dans la
main [ __ ] mais comment il fait le prof
qui a perdu les devoirs mais qui veut
pas le dire ce devoir d'iliad ya trois
mois
c'est plutôt passait bien je crois que
tu oui tout le monde a eu un tout le
monde a vraiment eu 20 la ranger ma
copine ta gueule vraiment eux-mêmes
s'applaudir je pense que le prof plus de
la gueule c'est très bien ton devoir
jimmy je voulais tant parler parce que
il ya quelques petites imperfections
c'est pas mal dans l'idée tu me
rappelais dire cruel dans l'échangé
économique
il ya un besoin de prêts fillon il est
encore temps ce toutes les coutures
formule la question pourquoi tout dans
l'autre ainsi peut-on développement
autres merci de profs berbère donc si tu
pouvais répondre
excuse moi tu t'investis l'ofaci
l'attention ap
faut être plus ferme sur le stylo c'est
important tout le ramasse the way hamas
la ramasse oui deuxième question tu peux
revenir en fait j'ai toujours rêvé en
histoire le roi clovis premier né en 400
soit d'étonnant à ce que je peux poser
une question simple et bien sûr qui
s'emballe totalement les couilles ici on
prend des couilles total en fait
j'ai toujours rêvé en aisé pour la
reproduction sexuelle on a vu la théorie
maintenant la pratique cyprien tu montes
au tableau du choisi une des plus belles
filles de la classe et tu nous montres
et toujours rêver en eps aux heurts ont
commencé par trois tours de terrain
c'est parti la tata d'abord pour
démontrer la wii j'ai toujours rêvé en
chemise et les citations nous venons de
concevoir de l'autre chaux maintenant on
va fabriquer une bombe
j'ai toujours rêvé en maths mais au prix
l'épée de l'intégrale sont vraiment très
très très importante
bonjour je suis un homme lambda cadres
en entreprise c'était juste pour vous
dire que tout ce que vous apprenez en
mathématiques
après la classe de 4e vous servira
jamais à rien du coût du conflit allait
en fait bien sûr les élèves à raison en
point il a raison j'ai toujours rêvé en
musique mais cette lutte
on s'en bat les couilles et où se prend
une guitare électrique dans la caisse
j'ai toujours rêvé en français et c'est
par cette animation cette ponctuation de
cette phrase que nous étudions
maintenant depuis deux heures que
gustave flaubert a voulu dénoncer la
pression à 1 subie par notre héroïne bon
joueur je suis gustave flaubert
alors vous dites que de la merde j'ai
jamais voulu dire ça vraiment que jamais
suisse ça sonnait bien
en plus mon livre il est super chiant
lisez plutôt divergentes en journée et
pas comment
[Musique]
oh je trouve ça va je comprends rien à
l'exercice